foreign
[Music]
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
we're doing another Cosmic queries these
have become fan favorites I guess I
understand why because you get to
participate well actually if you're a
patreon member you get to participate in
asking those questions at the entry
level of patreon today's topic
Infinity
with my friend and fellow physicist
Stefan Alexander we'll get to him in a
moment let me introduce my co-host
nageen facade Nadine it's been so long
oh my God hello yes I'm your your
honorary
um astrophysicist comedian friends
everybody needs one of those right minor
right minus any of the astrophysics just
to be clear none of that you are a host
of the the show fake the nation that's
right and in addition to fake the nation
you got some side gig where you've got a
succession recap what's up with that
that's right I'm doing a succession
recap put on the fake the nation feed
and I in addition to talking about space
I love talking about billionaires so
those are my two main interests right
now
um so yeah definitely subscribe to hear
all the succession chatter well help me
welcome my friend and colleague Stefan
Alexander Stefan your returning guest
you disappeared with us uh with when we
were on the Nat Geo Channel uh and you
had it it was a team natio TV episode
your theoretical physicist a cosmologist
a musician and an author and professor
of physics at Brown University up in
Providence Rhode Island
and among those books the one I remember
most is from now six years ago seven
years ago the Jazz of physics let me get
the right subtitle here the secret link
between music and the structure of the
universe
and then you follow that up with Fear of
a Black Universe an outsider's Guide to
the future of physics so you're still at
it but you're also a jazz saxophonist so
you're out of control here it seems uh
you also appeared in the 2022 Netflix
documentary a trip to infinity and that
is the subject of today Infinity which
boggles everybody's mind who's ever
thought about it and so could you just
tell us what Infinity can I tell you my
first encounter with infinity please so
I am five
when Kennedy is assassinated okay that's
how old I am and there's the burial and
they put him in in Arlington Cemetery
and there's a flame there at the burial
spot and they called it the eternal
flame
and I said what
does this flame never go out how could
it never go up what and and at age five
this with me okay sorry this was
like how at night do they secretly put
more oil in the flame you know but this
the camera doesn't show it I was and
then I would later learn yes that was
figurative that it's Eternal but there
is a formal mathematical concept called
Infinity
so
Nadine did you have any existential
angst over infinity at any time in your
life just to put that on put it on the
table right now because we got the man
who's going to straighten us out God I
feel I feel I mean it I had just an
existential angst as a teenager in
general and started reading all of the
works of Jean-Paul sarch as like a 16
year old and not fully understanding
that'll mess you up that'll mess you up
big time so that messed me up big time
and it led to a lot of brooding and a
lot of eye rolls on my part but um it
didn't it didn't freak me out the way
Infinity freaked you out okay okay all
right so Stefan tell me about Infinity
what's up with that let me admit
something to you and again
I don't know what Infinity is okay I
mean okay we're done here okay
bye everybody Nikki you got any jokes to
take us out
okay wow who wrote this guy I know right
right I think my first encounter with
infinity was just as a kid like you know
you you're taught how to count and you
say okay let me count one two three and
you realize that you could just go on
Counting for eternity
um you know at some point I think it was
a friend or a teacher I forget I was in
third grade he said actually there's
this number it's called infinity and so
basically once you get to the largest
possible number you can can you count it
and and infinity is that number that
goes on basically and of course to what
to Infinity it puts the the old geek
contest is what's the biggest number you
can name then you name it and say is
that plus one you know and that's how
you win you run the geek accounting
contest yeah exactly and then of course
there's um I think the other one I think
it's I want to say it's xenos Paradox so
Stefan what's your simplest example of
the of this of xenos paradox
well imagine you have this Turtle that's
trying to run 100 meters okay that's
funny just the thought of it but okay go
on okay found about 100 meters but the
rule is that every time he gets halfway
he has to go half of that so if you get
some 50 meters he has to now run 25
meters and once he gets to 25 meters he
has to run a half from that and it
continues successively doing that he
ends up getting never getting to 100
meters because you can always take the
remaining distance and cut it in half
and you all tend to remain distant and
cut it in half and so
yeah okay so this will just go on
forever that just goes on forever
exactly will he ever reach the 100 100
meter Mark according to this rule he
will never reach 100 100 meters mark
because he he just keeps you know
I'm covering half of the of the original
distance successively to the point where
you know it ends up being a half of
you know you know ends up B1 over
infinity
okay and so but the turtle does go the
100 meters so maybe that's what that's
what I guess Nagin I guess that's why
it's called a paradox okay
stopped in slow motion I can't go I
don't know why I'm in Infinity land I
mean no the turtle just walks and puts
his head across the finish line
and that's why it's a paradoxics today
how did it get to you know to the 100
meter if this is a possibility by taking
an infinite number of of havings yes yes
and it also it brings new meaning into
like let's go splitsies on something
because it's like if you keep you can't
you could just keep going splitsies and
it just never splits never never and
when I was a kid I thought I have a
solution there's a point where you have
atoms and how you go half the distance
when there's no more thing to have and
then that is just you just there that
was my solution when I was a kid that
actually is a nice solution to that
Paradox by the way yes you basically
reach the pixel size of space time and
then you can't have that pixel so you
grab that pixel and you're home free so
that was that was my suggestion you just
move on the game what was your solution
to xeno's Paradox when you were a kid my
solution was to get frustrated and then
go eat a bag of Funyuns and that's kind
of how I think
another place where we encounter
Infinity is just like let's look at um
fractions right I have one over two well
you if you tell a kid hey I'm gonna give
you half of a slice of pizza half of a
pile of pizza or one quarter of a pie of
pizza right the kid will know I want
half of the pie of pizza they know that
the larger you make that fraction of the
slice
why they got a smaller slice of pizza
you're going to get 1 16 of a slice of a
pizza
versus you know one quarter of a slice
of a pie right
you know the kid knows that the larger
that one over whatever it is of the
pizza they're gonna get a smaller piece
of the pie if you tell a kid you're
going to get one half
of the slice of a pie of pizza
yeah that's good if I say you get one
over one of the pizza
well a smart kill will say I get the
whole piece I get the whole pie one over
one
but now if I say
you get
if I make if I go smaller than one which
is
smaller than one is something that looks
like zero
one over zero then that number goes
that's what Infinity is
the number gets bigger a fraction gets
bigger and bigger and bigger the smaller
and smaller I make the bottom number
right so that's another place where we
encounter Infinity you left out the
middle part there so it was one over one
that's a pizza right that's the whole
part if it's one over a half oh it's two
that's two pies right there's two parts
a half goes twice into one right over
three that's three pies three parts
exactly one over a third very much yeah
so now if I do one over like you know
you know if I see keep because you said
one over one third one over one-fourth
whenever whatever now it'll go to one
over one maybe I get infinite price
right
um and that we call that a division by
zero and so computers crash actually
because you know if you Neil you so I
know that very well I used to write code
when you ask your physicist
um when you're a research asks for
physicist because somebody told me so
and um and so you know you support you
want to avoid these kind of things when
you wrote code these divisions by zero
because what would happen right yeah if
the program crashes yeah the crashes
exactly computer doesn't know what to do
with it by the way in Star Trek smoke
would come out of the computer if they
did
[Laughter]
are you trying to say the computer was
the computer was doing things that he
didn't want to do yeah yeah computer
would Captain Kirk without reason the
computer and then the smoke would come
out but in modern times no they just the
computer it just crashes yeah wait can I
this is actually giving me flashbacks of
when I first had to graph an asymptote
which is this is essentially right
asymptotic situation and I remember just
being like oh let them touch let the
thing touch
you you cared for them you wanted I
wanted them to clutch it felt you know
it just felt like uh a missed connection
forever you know well no they do they do
touch at Infinity
so get your ass to infinity and you'll
see it in touch
but right so Stefan asymptote is another
one of these Concepts right yeah it's a
great word it's a great word too right
it's a fun kind of you almost get there
but never quite until you go out to
Infinity
um and that's a very good that's another
in fact that's very relevant to physics
and by the way the ideas of the
asymptote and this division by zero all
of these things you know um does you
know touch you know have you know a deep
relationship with with physics and
astrophysics and cosmology so you're
saying it shows up in a lot of different
ways it shows up in a lot of different
ways and we
physicists you know there's of course
philosophers pillar of attention to
Infinities
mathematicians actually make a living
from it and we physicists try to run
away from it
I'm trying to see a mathematician Busker
on the street you know trying to make a
living off of infinity you know I don't
I can't try to picture that I don't I'm
sorry someone makes a living off
Infinity but but uh Nadine do you have
you have questions from from our patreon
members yeah I I absolutely do let me
dive in with a question from Captain
James Reilly
um they rate it always drives me crazy
when I hear that a singularity has
infinite density or that the universe is
infinite is this just something we label
things that we don't fully understand I
hate the concept of infinity it seems
like a cop-out I love that oh which is
how I felt about asymptotes so I'm
totally with you Captain Riley yeah so
so Stefan it's you know the captain's
got a point here you know are we just
invoking Infinity because we can't
otherwise solve the problem
uh yes or no um can we can we evoke one
of your favorite astrophysical objects
Neil what's black hole sure let's do it
because I think this is a perfect a very
good example of where you kind of get to
have your cake and eat it too because
here it is um interesting thing
um when Einstein came up with his theory
of general relativity which describes
you know how matter and energy can warp
the space design Fabric and create the
effect that we call gravity
um a mathematical prediction a
mathematical solution came out of that
um that theory this Theory spat out on a
very extreme
um sort of extreme walk in the space
time from from a very you know from a
basically a collapse a star that has
collapsed into a very dense region and
this thing is called a black hole and uh
Neil you've done some excellent um
reports on that in the past but just to
be clear Nagin he said that Einstein's
theory just spat out the equations for a
black hole but with the help of really
brilliant people who understood that
there
right right
it didn't just poop it out like yeah
yeah although I like the imagery of just
a bunch of numbers coming out of
someone's butt
it out on route to whatever it was doing
no no some brilliant people applied a
million people yeah to apply Einstein's
general relativity now that they have
that framework to arrive at a black hole
as a new under a new object a new
prediction yeah and it was a map it was
literally you know the Einstein studio
is 10 what we call 10 couple non-linear
partial differential equations very comp
very very
um difficult and still difficult to
solve so you're lucky when you get one
solution and the black hole solution
also Schwartz child solution named after
I think it was
um what's what's it called short child
thank you his nephew is Martin sorcel
who was at Princeton while I was there
actually had some good wisdom to share
but yeah Carl schwarzen who sadly died
in the field and during the first world
war so we're glad he banged out the
source child solution to black holes
before uh yeah and I'm going to be funny
now he didn't spit it out he'd hang it
up banged it out okay yeah
it was a majestical solution but at that
time like people some people and one of
my mentors David Finkelstein of the
Eddington Finkelstein coordinate system
which was based on Schwartz child's
solution about the event horizon right
the point of no return once you fall
into this black hole after it gobbles
you up you know this was seen by many to
just be some mathematical trickery some
mathematical solution that has not no
element of reality until of course we
found one
okay and we found many right
um now they're black hole Laboratories
out there okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and so the thing that I find
interesting about that was people
already knew
that the black holes this the reason why
they thought it was a mathematical
artifact or mathematical Goblin group of
this of of Einstein's theory
some some physicist thought was because
it actually had a singularity it
actually had an Infinity what do I mean
by that if you actually this is the idea
example we used before if you look at
the you know if I fall into a black hole
and I go if I
if I um
you know there's a scribe going in as
some the radius you know like a ball
think of the black holes a gigantic ball
in outer space a gigantic invisible dark
ball and as I go in
to the center of the black hole this
radius will eventually go to zero but if
I divide
and it turns out that the density and
the force
really falls off it actually decreases
as one over R sometimes one over r
squared one of R so what happens when an
R goes to zero you get an Infinity you
get an Infinity in the density the mass
density
and infinite density thank you you get
an affinity in the forces
right and you get an Infinity in the
curvature because the curvature becomes
infinite as well so so so I can okay so
I think the person who asks the question
knew that that's what you would say the
question is is that real is it yeah is
it no good good no this is interesting
I'm pretending I'm the dude who has I'm
the captain no you just making this you
just how can you have anything that's
infinite anything that's that's a
physical thing how is that even possible
we we agree you can do that
mathematically no one's arguing that now
you're going to tell me an actual
physical thing hits the infinity that
your math delivered yeah because like at
the end of the day if we're looking at
like a top if the black hole is in a
tupperware container right yes can it
then okay where are you going with this
and I'll stay with you go I was saying
like it can't it's infinitely dense the
Tupperware container is gonna break
right or whatever does that make any
sense
no that's actually so that's right so
what it's interesting that you you had a
theory that put out a sick solution so
many people thought that's not real but
then you find this thing in reality so
what do you do with the fact that this
Infinity is there in the prediction
um so then this is where you get
disagreements in amongst physicists and
astrophysicists some people say well
there's something that replaces that
theory
um meaning in general relativity there's
some new physics that we yet we do not
know
some people say you have to accept the
infinity
um and you know
something is censoring that Infinity
from actually realizing itself and
coming and doing coming out and doing
bad things
um in the world maybe this Horizon I
like that idea that nature might be
censoring our Infinities yes and so it
could it could be that the infinity is
the limit
of the applicability of this theory of
the universe that's that's that's the
take I take actually that's my okay
that's my I land on that's where I come
on okay where's the Tupperware go we go
I know I feel like you back to the
Tupperware really interesting yeah some
really expansive Tupperware okay
leftovers forever in your temper
leftovers right because it's infinitely
nuts it could feed everyone forever we
got to take a quick break but when we
come back more with Stefan Alexander
who's taken us
to infinity and beyond with of course my
co-host Nadine facade we'll be right
back we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries
we're talking about Infinity oh yeah and
we got one of the world's experts who
thinks about this subject Stefan
Alexander a friend and colleague
professor of physics at Brown University
Rhode Island and I got nagine facade
Nadine you wrote you wrote a book
a few years ago yeah just it was and I'm
trying to remember the title is it how
to make white people laugh or something
like that yes how to make white people
laugh Neil it wasn't for you no it
wasn't for me that's why I never I heard
about the book but I said no this is not
no no no
that's right it's a lot of big white
people so I remembered the title
correctly that's the title yeah that's
the one very cool still relevant still
need to make like white people laugh so
that's I want to make white people laugh
I might pick it up all right yeah yeah
check out the tricks of my train all
right all right the under the hood is as
they say okay so Stefan you were going
to add to the point about the black hole
Singularity being an infinite density
point and possibly others stepping in to
save the day
yes so there are there are other types
of singularities that show up in physics
that can maybe I think that where we
were able to what we call tame or cure
the singularity
[Music]
one was the electric charge and the
electric force so if we look at a
Charged particle
um like you know yeah good old charge
particle an electron or a magnet or a
magnet right
um the magnetic force also between two
magnets actually as I bring the magnets
closer together and closer together
actually turns out that that Force when
you go to zero distance
according to the equations that work
really well for all of our Motors and
all of our electric you know electricity
and all that wind energy and all that
stuff it uses the same physics that we
trust but according to this physics when
you go here all that good stuff goes out
the window because you get according to
the theory an infinite force and an
infinite amount of energy and we do not
measure that because the magnets touch
and nothing blows up and you're strong
enough to make the Matrix touch if
they're resisting each other that's
right you're strong enough to do that
but according to this thing the magnets
should never touch you can never be
strong enough because you require
infinite Force to make it in touch all
right but okay so what solved that
problem it turns out Richard Feynman and
you know his colleagues figured out
actually there's quantum physics going
on so what happens is that quantum
physics fuzzifies
and soft lens in a sense
like you know you just made up that word
fuzzify
I'm pretty sure but okay we know what
you mean let the record show okay making
up words as he goes along okay which by
the way which is what Infinity sometimes
sound like sounds like just throw in the
word infinity and that's exactly the
point of the question that sounds like a
cop out like it saysifies but continue
classifying Infinity okay so so this is
so weird things happen so in the quantum
world now if you say okay you know the
force between the magnets you know um is
really what we call a non-quantum or
classical Theory doesn't require Quantum
things what do you mean by a Quantum now
well it means that there are things
called quanta and in this case the thing
that becomes the quanta is light because
light is actually the thing that's
mediating
communicate in the fourth section and so
what fireman taught us is that you can't
no longer think about the magnetic field
as a magnetic field but actually as a
particle called a photon that gets
transmitted balancing back and forth and
that's a photon goals is communicating
this force and the magnet gets closer
and closer the photon can actually you
know do weird things you can do weird
quantity okay but the point is you are
saving the magnetic field problem
invoking quantum physics yes yes is
quantum physics going to save you from
the center of the black hole from The
Singularity very good so there are now
people not people they're great
physicists um
um that argue like Stephen Hawking being
one and get out of tuft and Lenny suskin
and others that said ah what if what
happened with you know with my real
magnets
um by analogy there's something Quantum
what Quantum quantum gravity there's
something to do with gravity being a
Quantum having a Quantum effect what if
that would like jump in and save today
and as I go into the singularity of a
black hole you don't get Infinity but
you get new Quantum effects what would
that look like you'd have to marry
quantum physics with Einstein relativity
for that you have to do that and it's
some kind of shotgun wedding right some
kind of shotgun
but here's the
problems are happy
here's a funny thing if gravity and
quantum mechanics were to be a couple
they're very incompatible with each
other every reconcilable differences
that disallow them from actually making
a bond yeah all right it's like when
I've tried to date a Pisces it never
works out you know I could have told you
that why did you call me
so that's so that's the we replied to
the captain whether or not we fully
satisfied his question so what are the
questions you got again all right let's
let's very first question
actually just it's just David he's like
Madonna he just goes by the one
um I once heard Alex philippenko explain
Infinity in our universe is
operationally infinite infinite to us
because we can never achieve the edges
of it not even at the speed of light
because space is expanding faster than
the speed of light almost like going up
an escalator that is going faster than
you can walk up it you'll never reach
the top is my small mind grasping this
concept of an infinite universe and if
so or if not how do multiple universes
fit into our intimate infinite Universe
I love those questions but I love that
escalator metaphor because it if that if
that's right that puts things into
making sense for me
right right
well I'm going to ask my I'm going to
ask my colleague Neil to to um summarize
that question for me okay so the way the
way I look at it is and I can I can
contribute a little bit to this answer
all right so I'll contribute two parts
you take care of the rest so yes if the
universe is expand and Alex filopenko is
a colleague of mine we came up together
actually in Graduate School uh and so if
you
um if you have an infinite universe
that's expanding right you'll never
reach the edge like and I'd love like
you said we all agree that escalator
analogy is excellent however
you don't need an infinite Universe to
never reach the edge
for example
the surface of the Earth is not infinite
yet you could just keep walking and
never reach the edge
so don't equate reaching an edge with
something having to be infinite
because the space can turn back on
itself
and you can end up just making loops and
and never stop walking and always walk
in the same direction
whichever which direction you choose and
you'll never get to the edge just that
my first point to that and the second
point is if you embed so I can have a
sheet of paper
that's infinite
infinite okay
now but a sheet of paper is two
Dimensions I can have another sheet of
paper
that's infinite
and put them one centimeter apart from
each other and they will never intersect
even though they're both infinite
because I pulled one into a third
dimension
and so when you embed Infinities in
higher Dimensions you got no problems at
all you can crap put them in
cram has many as you want and then
there's plenty of room
so you take it from there Stefano
you you took all the good examples oh no
no no well I'm gonna yeah there's
another there's another
um and of course you know there's um
infinite time
oh you can have a finite world
but the clock can continue ticking for
you know for an Infinity
and um you know so that's that's an
that's another example of of um
you know meaning that the Universe um
could be fined by an extent but just
continue expanding for an Infinity
um so the universe is like a is like a
vampire that never dies in that scenario
nagine it's exactly like this
great got it just wanted to explain for
the listeners minus the blood minus the
blood that's okay and just to follow up
on what you just said Stefan so if the
spherical universe
were expanding you would still have a
finite universe but you could walk in it
forever even though it's expanding so
there's a lot of variations on this
geometry that make for fascinating
thought
absolutely absolutely and in fact um one
of the great mathematicians um Adam
um you know somebody that you know Neil
he went off and made a lot of money but
he literally you know he he put a lot of
money towards this the satellite so that
he can you know know about the Big Bang
called a Simon's Observatory oh yes yes
Jim Simons he's he's a geometry so he
came up with some some important
mathematics all about this topic he
believes he wants to put his belt that
the Universe actually is finite it's a
what you know a sphere it has a
spherical geometry
and
if you you know if you play with it if
you play with the assumptions and the
data and the statistics enough
you might be able to still accommodate
um that the Universe actually might be
finite in terms of the data
um so that's interesting
side note and and just for in case
people don't know Jim Simons uh made his
billions trading in the stock market
bringing high-level mathematics to his
predictive models that no one knew was
even possible at the time and and now
he's put his money back to further
research this assignments Foundation the
Simon's Center for uh research in
physics biology and Computing which is
right here in downtown Manhattan Oh I
thought you were going to say which is
on a yacht because that's what he gets
to afford now he does have a yacht and
I've been on his yacht and it's called
and it's called the Archimedes of course
of course yes yes so thank you for that
for queuing that was your cue
time for another question yeah please
please so from Gavin Bamber he says
hello from North Vancouver please visit
kin String Theory be represented by
music if so would it be more of a
monophony classical or Jazz would it be
a complete composition or would it
continue on into Infinity wait is that a
word monotony is that is that like does
that mean a one note concert what do you
say in there that's what it sounds like
to me but maybe it's something else oh
my God I have two of the smartest people
on the planet and and none of us know if
that's like a word
well this is actually a good point to
actually talk about um you know going
back to the firemen so and his
colleagues that they use quantum
mechanics to smoothen out for like a
better words the the infinitize the
infinity that I'm gonna put a new word
okay we're up to six new words this
episode all right keep going
and you know there is now a you know an
Uber quantum theory and that theory is
called String Theory
um and it turns out that
just when you thought that quantum
mechanics actually would help with
Infinities it turned out that quantum
mechanics itself had infinities
okay and we call these things
divergences or you know instabilities
these are all words that just basically
mean that things in your theory go to
Infinity okay
um so anyway so in a long it turns out
you're saying quantum physics was
brought on to possibly help with the
classical Infinities but then it
introduces Infinity Infinities of its
own that's correct yes right that ain't
right that ain't right right and um
these things are called like ultraviolet
or infrared Divergence for the audience
member who want to get fancy
um okay
um so it turns out that String Theory
actually one of the reasons why many
people got behind String Theory
including a younger version of myself
uh when I was a young research younger
researcher
um was that it actually was an Infinity
free Theory quantum theory that actually
that contained gravity in it as well
contain you know aspects of all the
forces but you have to live in ten
Dimensions okay uh
um there's some some give
um
no and going back to what Neil exactly
said is that now that you have the all
these other dimensions you can go and
stuff Infinities on those in those other
dimensions now right
um but anyway string theory is such a
such a theory that does that
um it does it's an it's a theory that
does not have in its mathematical
structures and the solution it spits out
and it does not have Infinities so we
all love that it's elegant and beautiful
and
um it's also a musical Theory that's
correct so you're you're um
um your member
is quite right to say that string theory
has a musical sense of and I'm happy to
to speak to that I do want to hear what
you have to say about strength Theory
and music because that is a part of the
the questioners uh content but we got to
take a quick break when we come back the
third and final segment of infinity
does infinity have three segments
come back and find out on StarTalk
Cosmic queries
we're back third and final segment of
cosmic queries queries the infinity
Edition with Stefan Alexander a
physicist who's thought a lot about
cosmology and Infinities and of course
Nagin Prasad nagine hello I'm having you
here it's been too long come back more
often okay absolutely yeah yeah all
right but I'm I'm on nearly every show
in other dimensions
so
you have to go to the other dimensions I
think is what's going on and if you
don't tell me that Dimension I will
never find you right you'll be fine I'll
be found only when you allow yourself to
be found I've also got hot dog fingers
in those other dimensions yes oh okay
everything everywhere all at once I
think that was yeah so Stefan why would
strength Theory have to do with music at
all just because it has the word string
in it and just because their music has
string instruments I don't know
it's a weird connection yeah it feels
like really weak yes
well it's yeah so um they should just
call it maybe something like
um guitar string theory
um but yeah you know so
String Theory One Good Reason Waze was
able to solve these Infinities have to
do what an assumption that we made about
even our physical pre-string Theory
which is that things fundamentally are
made up of Point particles and the
minute you talk about a particle then
you're forced to go to zero with and
that's when things blew up on you the
infinity revealed itself but if and the
idea of string theory is that replace
nothing is ever made up of a point
particle anymore when you even when you
take a magnifying glass and you you try
to resolve that point and so what looks
like a point from really really far away
like this thing here
is that a point yeah all right I'm
faking it to look like a point okay yep
and then he's far away so it's a point
zoom in and you realize it's a string
but it's not just any old string the
string because it's Quantum has to be
vibrated
and we know very well the physics of any
kind of vibrant strain the vibrating
strength generates a spectrum or uh you
know generates um characteristics types
of waves and these waves are called
standing waves what is the standard wave
it's basically what you know as a note a
tone a particular type of vibration
um that can be represented as a sound
um or you know a note on the piano so
like when I play a note on a piano
what's really going on is that there's a
piano string hit him and that piano
string is vibrating and because it
vibrates it undulates at a very at a
given rate that rate of vibration call a
frequency denotes what we call a tone or
sound and so so String Theory the
physics of strings really does match on
very nicely okay so the physics of how
notes are generated in instruments all
right so sorry to bad mouthy at the
front of it I'm sorry yeah Nadine needs
to apologize too
so sorry
um
it's an analogy it's an analogy but it's
a reality I get it I get it
again keep going
Jose Marcelino had a question that feels
related to that
um he's he's writing from Dallas Texas
he wrote I was wondering do sound waves
have any mass and if so what is the
difference in Mass created by the sounds
of musical instruments versus The Sounds
created by a computer
okay well sound waves do have mass
because actually
the scientific word for a sound wave is
what we call a pressure wave
so anytime like I create any sort of
change in the pressure it could be the
pressure of on you know that's why you
can hear sounds underwater because even
the the water is compressing and
decompressing and that compression in
the pressure right higher and lower
pressure and for things that to do that
they have to have mass
um to actually create a change in the
pressure so the medium the medium has
mass the medium but does the sound have
mass
very good
um well I get a lot of earwax so I feel
like that's an indicator TMI TMI
but is that just the mass of all the
sound that I'm hearing oh oh you
collected in your in your life you
collected in your ear canals that's a
new you got to take it out with a Q-tip
I don't know
you totally are okay
all right the carry of the sound the
thing that's carrying the sound okay
um has mass like right but actually you
know you can say then it's a very deep
question actually because our perception
of the sound you know sound is massless
in that sense but
but still has energy and energy equals m
c squared so there's a mass equivalent
to the energy that's in the sound I
presume that's that's absolutely true
that is okay all right so that Bells
them out of that one yeah yeah all right
and again see how many more questions
you can squeeze in Stefan are you good
at sound bites
I can try Okay okay so rapid fire
section here we go the anthropo from
anthropo cosmic Dylan
um in San Diego writes question for Dr
Alexander Neal says quote the universe
is under no obligation to make sense to
us so how do the concepts of infinity
and quantum mechanics get distorted due
to our human condition and how do you
reconcile this Gap with your research
and your artistic expression through
jazz music whoa
let me tighten up the beginning of that
so so he's asking if if I say the
universe is under no obligation to make
sense to you
uh are you do these Infinities make
sense to you and does it bother you or
do you keep going do you just accept it
or because it doesn't make sense you
have to do something about it and then
violate the Neil principle
very good I I like the Neil principle I
hear through it actually because it
doesn't make sense to me a lot of times
but you know but I have to pay my bills
continue
my take on this I've actually embraced
the Infinities I embrace it I said let's
live with the Infinities and wherever we
can try to sidestep it and make progress
and um yeah I see okay
so you kind of even if they're difficult
um it doesn't shouldn't prevent you from
making other kinds of discoveries uh in
the terrain that surrounds them I get it
okay and how about that and again the
second part was about jazz what was the
read that again yeah uh they wrote
um how do you reconcile this Gap with
your research and your artistic
expression through jazz music
yeah I mean you know one of the things
that's great about jazz music is that
you know you for you know it's a a dual
thing you you're always struck striving
to master your craft and you know and
build on the foundations of others but
you also must
try to break the rules and stumble and
fall to make something new based on that
foundation so really embracing the
mistakes that you made and not being
afraid of that that's kind of what Jazz
improvisation is also about while at the
same time building on the foundation and
getting your traps together and
practicing and all that good stuff and
there's surely some people who would say
would would invoke the new the nihilism
on jazz jazz is under no obligation to
make sense to you very good
I want to hear your thoughts about very
quickly um when I first heard on it
Coleman I was like what kind of I
made no sense it didn't make any musical
sense and then much later on in life as
I thought I became more um Advanced
musically it started making sense to me
oh okay all right so it doesn't have to
make sense up front that's right also in
in uh just uh for for when Jazz doesn't
make sense I usually go to the bar get
another drink and then yeah that starts
to make a lot of sense right that's why
jazz is in bars that's why and also why
all physicists and astrophysicists
should be drinking when they talk about
Infinity
well I learned something very cool about
it I'm very proud of this I always feel
like I was in the outside of physicists
that played music it turned out that the
hero the guy that won the Nobel Prize
for figuring out how to actually deal
with Infinities and our Quantum fuel
theory that led to the discovery of the
Higgs boson his name is Ken Wilson I
just found out that he played the oboe
like you know when he was a postdoc yeah
except I don't know that the oboe shows
up much in jazz concerts well now it
should I'm pretty sure that that was not
a first choice but
I know the elbow feels like something
you just get saddled with in Middle
exactly
you're in elementary school that was you
would last in line
oboe here no he's now he's saddled with
a Nobel oh okay
well let's take a question from Bruce
Ryan Bruce writes
um I saw that Stefan's specialty
includes Quantum Loop gravity and I've
always wanted to ask what the heck is
quantum Loop gravity yeah me too me too
count me in that question as well those
that the the
other theorists that do not like the
fact that I used to work on the Congress
or still think about it so they said it
was loopy
that doesn't sound good that sounds like
being saddled with the oboe okay yeah
it's a beautiful it is it's a very
timefulizing idea and it actually does
deal with in with gravitational
Infinities and in some respects and the
idea is really interesting you know like
how let's go back to a picture of the
magnet you know if you actually can see
a magnetic field line um with these iron
filings you see that it's like but it's
concentrated in like a tube like a
magnetic tube well what Loop quantum
gravity is saying is uh imagine that you
can make tubes of gravitational fields
and sort of loop them around like um
like chains like you know like a chain
but I can have a link in a chain like a
link in a chain and I can link I can
link a fabric of space sign with those
with those Loops like um right um like
those those remember those um those um
t-shirts those Jamaican guys used to
wear
um you know with with the little holes
anyway so um I'm sorry I don't know that
doesn't ring a bell at all yeah neither
with me and I'm and I'm in this
hemisphere yeah exactly right right so
he inhales from some other summertime
two Hem of three years away and I don't
I think we don't have no idea so it's
like yeah imagine you zoom into my
fabric this fabric of the show it like
loops and links and that kind of stuff
so that's the idea of Lupine gravity but
what's linking is a gravitational feel
and they're kind of you can think of
them as atoms of space
so um yeah so I should do not Amazon
pixels or space even better yeah even
better pixels of space yes the smallest
unit of space yeah small student space
and I mean that idea that theory is
still in play in fact I will be seeing
the founders of that theory about very
soon
they're especially loopy yeah especially
yeah yes they love roller coaster rides
too
[Laughter]
all right now we might have time for one
maybe one and a half more questions okay
so let's see abanov yadav from Philly
asks I struggle to think about
space-time as a concept that exists in
our daily lives as a medium though which
light wave travels as a medium though
which light wave travels as a fabric
that gets shaped by mass and as a vacuum
out of which virtual particles pop in
and out of what's an easier way to think
about space time
what was that what was that question
wait space time is all those things so
what is the question I guess yeah
there's like there's a there's a
grammatical something missing that's
making it hard yeah we need some
semicolons but with some semicolons but
all those things are true right Stefan
they're all going on in space time right
yes what's the easiest way of thinking
about the concept of of space-time okay
so if all that's going on in space time
yeah what's the first way you teach it
you don't dump the the bucket onto
people before they know what's going on
what's your first step to say what space
time is
to like a kid
um yeah so I would say that yeah I I
think it's I think it's a good analogy
to think of space-time as some sort of
very very faint and invisible
um fabric
um
that but it's a special kind of effect
because that fabric can also support
space-time itself to move along like
gravitational waves right so space time
could sell can actually support motion
of uh ripples up itself and it and that
is different than any other types of
medium that we know right normally
something like like an electric feel or
particles need space time to move
through but they can't move through
their own their own medium space-time
has a it's a very special type of medium
in that sense but um it's a very weird
medium a lack of a better word it's what
we call it's every it's a relational
medium okay
and nor is it under any obligation to
make sense to us yes okay
what you described it makes no sense to
me yeah
so the answer to this person's question
is basically there's no way of really
thinking about it in your daily life
no I mean again this is what what Neil
just said makes no sense but I know I
could write down this object called a
space-time metric and we describe it as
a field of you know it's based on some
kind of a field but again these are just
words that we attach to the equation is
that we we write down yeah but they make
predictions and they work so they make
very good predictions and they work very
well yeah so that's why however
Fantastical they sound they still are
connected to reality in that important
way so I mean the detection of
gravitational waves with ligo and Virgo
yep yeah yeah yeah again I think we got
one more question so I mean this is sort
of like related everyone seems to be
having a crisis and understanding but
Malcolm mark fan from Trinidad and
Tobago says Infinity is often described
as a mathematical abstraction how can we
know that the concept of infinity exists
in the physical world and not just in
our minds they are really testing you
today yeah they are it's definitely they
want Hard Answers and I tell you I
remembered learning Infinity
mathematically and they said one divided
by zero is undefined okay I remember
being taught that in my math class well
I have a math friend who we've actually
had as a guest
um John Allen paulos Professor math at
Temple University outside of Philly and
I tweeted I called him out in in Twitter
and I said John
if one one divided by zero is undefined
why don't you guys Define it
what are you waiting for okay
I've been waiting my whole life and all
you have to do is Define it and we're
cool what's up with that so
so apparently to him Infinity is
undefined because 1 divided by zero is
infinity kind of
so wait I so this thing is just totally
up for grab like I could just do it a
journal right like a journal article
right now and just be like one divided
by Infinity is a bowl of jello and like
that if this is the grabs I'd like to
take a stab we have to put closure on
your theory and one divided by zero is
an asymptote captured in tupperware
that's beaut I mean that's beautiful and
that that that's a that's a beautiful
theorem right there right there we got
to call it quits there Stefan great to
have you back on the show thanks for
having me again Neil and it's great to
to meet you I look forward to checking
yourself off sure so great to meet you
all right Nadine it's been a delight and
and by the way Nadine just quickly
weren't you on TV with Hillary Clinton
did I I'm channel surfing that's Nadine
wait that's Hillary Clinton
doing yeah what was that briefly tell me
real quick I'm on the show gutsy on
Apple TV um Hillary Clinton is just
basically
um doing a series about gutsy women and
I and crazily I um I'm one of them so
check it out
okay it's just called getsy yeah it's
called gutsy on Apple TV let's see very
cool but I don't mean to I don't mean to
brag but Hillary Clinton said I'm her
favorite astrophysicist oh oh yeah I'm
sure I'm pretty sure she knows only one
extra this is that's the problem
no I mean hey that should uh if I had
that it would be on you know I would
take it would be on my gravestone but be
there I was okay oh the best is when I
meet my favorite musician and and he
goes hey by the way can you can you can
you get me introducing Neil deGrasse
Tyson please
all right guys we're done here Land This
Plane this has been Star Talk Cosmic
queries the infinity Edition it's
Delight to have an old friend and
colleague Stefan Alexander and nagine
persad always good to have you back
Neil deGrasse Tyson here as always
beating you
keep looking up
[Music]